let's go to our next caller from the
9:36 area code caller from 936 what's
going on hello David this is Jason from
Houston Texas I used to be a hardcore
conservative but now I'm a huge fan of
your show
okay the two aren't necessarily be truly
exclusive you could be a hardcore
conservative and a fan of the show -
well actually I changed from watching
your show and I'm very proud of that
because now we're talking on my parents
are yeah there there used to be thinking
that the US was gonna reinvade Texas and
a number of other things there Alex
Jones fans okay and now I feel like
since social media is taking such a root
in our culture yeah but it's really
polarized people and my parents used to
be very peaceful people who had several
views that were conservative but now
they're really been full on certain
issues like that and my question is with
Trump is the president now and acting as
a catalyst for all these people to come
out of the Woodworks and spread this
type of agendas do you think that the
world stage is actually going to just
wait this presidency out or is this now
the view of Americans from the world
stage I guess well there's two things
going on simultaneously and you're
thinking about it the right way one is
that countries would be understandably
skeptical about getting into deals with
Trump because as we saw he just backed
out of the Iran deal even though Iran
didn't violate that deal he says one
thing and then Jim mattis or John Kelly
or whoever say now we we don't know
anything about that we're doing this
other thing so like from a pragmatic
standpoint why would anyone do business
with this guy that's number one number
two I do believe that there are
countries that are simply going to
circumvent the United States for the
duration that Trump is president like on
climate issues Trump says he's pulling
out of the Paris climate deal
he said that climate changes a hoax from
the Chinese in order to stimulate their
manufacturing industry so other
countries just won't deal with the u.s.
they'll kind of move full full speed
ahead the downside to that is that the
u.s. is one of the big polluters so you
kind of want the US is involvement so I
think it's going to be a little bit of
both but if I can I want to go back to
something you said Jason so if I
understand correctly you used to be a
conservative but the David Pakman show
programmed you and now you're a
progressive your parents used to be
moderate conservatives and they after
watching Alex Jones have become extreme
is that what you're saying yes man
that's not good I mean is that is that
difficult for you and your relationship
with your parents there's yeah there's a
definite schism in our family after that
and we really haven't spoken in pretty
much a year now I mean when we do it's
kind of it becomes a heated debate every
time and it seems like they don't want
it I tried to show them some of your
videos because they're very enlightening
on some subjects thank you and it
doesn't seem to get through I don't know
like what what what do the I'm just
what do your Alex Jones fan parents say
when you show them a David Pakman show
video will they tell me they look at it
and if they don't have the time to do
research anymore yes when I go on social
media they're still posting memes and
stuff really talked about issues that
have been explained like the means that
people pass around telling each other
back there's perhaps Christians are a
minority in America being crass and sure
you're law going around and yeah in our
country it's not it's not happening and
ya know Jason that's horrible I'm really
sorry to hear that and if I played any
role in this schism that is developed I
you know my sincere apologies I that's
horrible and to think they had a role in
that I feel really bad definitely not
thank you for your influence and help
I've been able to actually help other
people come to to better ways to find
logic and reasoning your videos on that
has really helped that there are a lot
more smoothly unless I don't know how
you're able to do that but when you
disagree with people you seem to do in a
very non aggressive manner I don't know
how to do that myself well thank you I
really appreciate it Jason a pleasure
hearing from you and best of luck with
what's going on with the family
appreciate the call all right thank you
Wow Wow kind of mixed feelings about
that one because on the one hand yeah
you helped him see the light and come
around to the right positions on the
other hand it sounds like we're causing
family separation yeah
break up and we don't want that I don't
I mean you know let's move on